Genesis 32243 yeah yeah so my question
is just so the man was God and he lost
so how can God lose God right man this
was the first UFC match yeah and God
lost the
championship you see the man touched
Jacob socket right his uh yeah yeah and
then he made Jacob crippled the rest of
his life right uhhuh and that's why the
Jews do not eat the meat from that area
the sinu in honor of Jacob what does it
tell you about the power of the man if
one touch he can make him
yeah okay I see me what can he
do to him yeah can eat him up yeah okay
so why did he not eat him up I'm gonna
explain this he's asking about how did
God lose the first UFC
Championship right how did God lose the
first UFC championship
all let's go through this I've talked
about this but we'll talk about it again
okay let's here first of all God already
shows you that he could kill him if you
wanted to yeah it says and he he saw
that he had not prevailed against so he
touched the socket of his thigh and so
the sock of Jacob's thigh was dislocated
while he wrestled with him now watch 31
32 and the sun rose up upon him just as
he crossed over panu and he was limping
on his thigh he left him a
okay watch here
therefore to this day the sons of Israel
did not eat the senu of the hip which is
on the socket of the thigh because he
touched the socket of Jacob's thigh in
the S of the hip so right there you're
told that this man could have just
killed them snapped them with one touch
one now what if he touched his neck what
would he've done to
him send him to Abraham exactly now why
did he lose because I'm going to give
you the picture you have a son and you
wrestle your son you don't make it too
easy for him but not too
hard and you make sure that he earns it
you make him sweat and fight until he
pins you because you want to teach your
son a lesson right you want to help your
son you want to train your son you want
to discipline your son you want to
strengthen your son
correct so the point of this wrestling
match the point of this wrestling match
this is the point Jacob if you've been
reading from Genesis if you read from
Genesis
29 all the way through in fact if you
start in Genesis 25 but 29 it starts a
big that it's yeah start in Genesis
27 because 25 is when Isaac marries
rebeccaa and he's six years old and she
gets pregnant with twins right and gives
birth to twins and if you start from 27
on you're going to see a story Jacob and
and his mother are plotting deceiving
conniving and lying to get their way
right mhm because what did Jacob do with
the help of his mother to get Isaac to
bless him she killed a goat
right took the skin of the goat put it
on
Jacob and then gave Isaac
stew and then when he went and he told
the father Isaac bless me because
Isaac's eyes had gone dim he couldn't
see
right you with me there mhm Isaac's eyes
went di couldn't see when he went there
he touched him he goes the hair is Esau
but the voice is Jacob because Jacob
pretended to be someone he's not he goes
bless me father and he blessed him
because Isaac loved Esau more than he
loved Jacob but RKA loved Jacob more
than he loved more than she loved
Isa who was rea's
favorite Jacob Jacob who was Isaac's
favorite Isa was like a warrior a hunter
man's man so he
told Isa go and fetch me some stew so
that means Esa went hunting in order to
get an animal to in order to make stew
for his father
right during that time
RKA helped Jacob make stew and put gold
hair on him to deceive Isaac into
thinking this jacob so he blessed him
and gave him the blessing of the
firstborn
listen Esau comes and Isaac's like who
is this he goes it's me Esau how can it
be you you're already here what do you
mean oh man your brother came and CLA
pretended to be you and I gave him the
blessing and he started crying you gave
him the blessing of the firstborn bless
me he goes yes I can't revoke that
blessing so too bad so sad I bless your
your brother ahead of you and you will
now serve him meaning your descendants
will be a servant to Jacob's descendant
and Esau was angry and swore to murder
Jacob you guys listening to the
background I got to give you the
background May the spirit help me recall
the facts perfectly destroy all error
and sin in me and protect me to give you
the truth and we live it glory to the
father spirit so everyone with me so far
Jacob is now afraid he has to take off
he flees so sends him to her brother's
house Le I got to give you the history
now right you guys okay with this I got
to give you a Bible Lesson you got to
understand the background Jacob ends up
at his mother's brother's home leban is
his uncle from his mother's side lean
are brother
sister so he starts working for leban
leban turns out to be a conver and
deceiver who cheats Jacob out of his
wages so you see the principle in the
Bible is called reaping what you sow
what you plant you're going to get back
right M same measure used will be used
against you
right so and Jacob deceived Isaac now
Jacob is gonna find a deceiver who makes
him look humble someone who's now going
to deceive the deceiver
right because he made a deal with leban
because he had two daughters Leah and
Rachel Leah and
Rachel so he fell with Rachel because it
says if you read the scripture Genesis
29 and 30 it says that Leah's eyes were
not that fair she wasn't as pretty as
her younger sister Rachel was beautiful
and Jacob was in love with Rachel oh she
was the monicaa baluchi Kim Kardashian
of her day you with me there you know
Monica baluchi no good don't see her
because then you're going to have to go
to confession you know Kim kashian
before she had PL plastic surgery no
good don't see her because you're going
to have to go to confessions keep your
eyes pure and virginal anyway so Rachel
was the Monica baluchi he was in love
with her so he told lebman I want to
marry her my cousin he goes okay you
have to work for me for seven years so
he worked seven years and it says Jacob
was so in love with Rachel that the
seven years seemed like a a day that's
how fast the time went because he's
thinking I'm gonna have Rachel I'm gonna
have Rachel
H so they celebrate for a week Wedding
Banquet that that time they celebrate
seven days H who he then he goes into
the tent now brother remember there is
no electricity there is no lights you go
into the tent it's pitch
dark so then guess what lebman does that
sneak you know what he does you know he
he sends Leah not
Rachel the older sister and he can't see
it's dark
and like when RKA saw Isaac it says she
put on a veil so it's dark no light she
comes in do
a time to make some babies yeah baby so
she goes into the tent he sleeps with
her he gets up in the morning and then
you hear a scream from padanam all the
way to South America that's how loud he
screamed
it turns out it's
Leah and now he's shocked and angry why
did you do this to me why did you
deceive me I worked seven years
for Rachel he says well it's
not our custom to marry off the younger
daughter before the older one so he says
I'll give you Rachel but you have to
work for me for another seven
years so you see what God is teaching
you mhm you reap what you sow if you
plant you get back what you plant so if
you're planting deception guess what's
going to come back to
you
deception if you deceive people guess
what's going to happen to you you'll be
deceived because there's always someone
who's going to be a bigger deceiver than
you a bigger cheater than you and
smarter than you and manipulate you
right so lean turned out to be
an even bigger cheat and conniver than
his
nephew so now he works for 14 years
because he got an extra woman he didn't
want but I'm going to now when I finish
answering the question I'm going to show
you the heart of God for Leah I'm gonna
show you how beautiful God is how fair
God is how merciful god is I'm G to get
there
so then leban cheats him out of his
wages he's making deals with him where
leban gets more of the flock and Jacob
gets less of the flock so he's cheating
him so Jacob one night decides to escape
so he takes his two wives and their maid
servants because he was having sex with
four women the guy was busy they had no
TV back then so you know all he had to
do was just when he's finished working
jump in bed with whatever he wanted four
women from these four women he had 12
sons so he takes off running leban
chases after him but God warns not to
mess with him not to harm with him so
what is the story the story of Jacob is
he has been running from his problems he
doesn't face his problems he tries to
find ways to get out of his problems out
of difficult circumstances and the ways
that he uses is to lie deceive and
connive so now God is going to teach him
a lesson now the context now you want to
know what the context is
you ready mhm here's the
context God now appears as a man and
forces him to wrestle him and teaches
him you will not be blessed by running
from your problems and using
trickery to escape your trials you know
when you're going to be blessed when you
stand as a man struggle with your
problems and keep struggling until you
conquer them then you will receive the
blessing that's what he's teaching
him you got it here so that's why he
says let me go because he's teaching
Jacob you do not let go until you get
the
blessing you understand what he's
teaching him here let me go and if Jacob
had let him go he would have not
received the blessing
because when did Jacob receive the
blessing did he receive it when his
father
bless no he received it here when God
appeared and changed his
name yeah yeah no when Isaac blessed him
God did not bless him because God does
not bless lies deceit trickery and
conniver God hasn't blessed that sin
that's why Jacob suffered all life CU
God was teaching him the consequence and
see when you keep lying and conniving
and you keep taking matters in your own
hand and you use con iory to escape your
problems you're only going to delay the
blessing because I will not bless you in
sin I don't bless sin I bless obedience
trust faithfulness Holiness and
love yeah this also does this also count
for good things it does right say it
again so let's say you do good things um
God gives you um these good things in
your life too right well it depends on
what no no you have a wrong view of God
Jesus did good things and they spit on
him beat him and killed him and it
depends on why you good do are you doing
good things because you want Praise of
men you want good things so people think
you're a great Christian are you doing
good things because you want something
from God if that's your motive then your
heart is
corrupt now I do good things to show my
love for God I go do good things to show
my trust in God I do good things because
I want to thank God for what he's
already done for me and who he
is not God hey I'll do this if you give
me this that's like you're making a
bargain with
God that's that's sin that's
wickedness okay that's the very sin that
Satan accused job the reason why he
loves you and does what you tell him
because of the things you've given him
so you're falling for Satan's
trap are you with me
there okay now that we got
it okay so what's the god telling him
stop you got to face your problems let
me
go Daybreak see he says let me go don I
will not let you go unless you bless me
so here Jacob is fighting and wrestling
and struggling all night that means he's
sweating he's getting tired he's getting
fatigued he's getting physically hurt
but I won't let go no ah no no you're go
and he learned the lesson and then he
says this so he said to him what is your
name he said Jacob then he said your
name shall no longer be Jacob but Israel
for you have served with God and with
men have prevailed now watch Jacob the
name means Deceiver
he goes Jacob you will no longer be
known as The Deceiver because I've come
to change your character your name is
means he who wrestled with God and Men
struggled with God and men and overcame
his adversity in order now conquer and
Rule you will now be known as the one
who has conquered in order to gain the
right to rule but now notice what he
said
he goes because you wrestled you've
striven you struggled with God and men
and you overcame you didn't give up when
did he wrestle with God and men and
when when did he wrestle with God and
men and
win oh is the question to me no it's for
my friend Timmy
Timmy when did he wrestle with God and
men and when um just uh at this uh
particular day in in the night right
here because who appeared to him a man
who's God so when he wrestled with the
man he wrestled with the man and he
wrestled with that man he was wrestling
God and he
won because this was the god man right
yeah so here's where he's wrestling with
God and man because it's God appearing
as a man so when he wrestled a man he
wrestled with God and he goes now you've
overcome you've struggled with me you
didn't give up and you didn't let me go
until I blessed you and now I showed you
that's how you have to face men you
don't run from men you face men and
trust that I'm with you and you will
conquer that's the message